[Music]
Hey,
good morning AI engineers. Um, so when I
signed up for this talk, I said I was
going to give a review of the last year
in LLMs. With hindsight, that was very
foolish. This space keeps on
accelerating. I've had to cut my scope.
I'm now down to the last six months in
LLMs, and that's going to keep us pretty
busy. Um, ju just covering that much.
Um, the problem that we have is I
counted 30 significant model releases in
the past six months. And by significant,
I mean if you are working in the space,
you should at least be aware of them and
somewhat familiar, like have a poke at
them. That's a lot of different stuff.
And the classic problem is, how do we
tell which of them are any good? There
are all of these benchmarks full of
numbers. I don't like the numbers. There
are the leaderboards. I'm kind of
beginning to lose trust in the
leaderboards as well. So, for my own
work, I've been leaning increasingly
into my own little benchmark, which
started as a joke and has actually
turned into something that I I rely on
quite a lot. And that's this. I prompt
models with generate an SVG of a pelican
riding a bicycle. I have good reasons
for this. Um, firstly, these are not
image models. These are text models.
They shouldn't be able to draw anything
at all, but they can output code and SVG
is a kind of code. So, that works.
Pelican riding a bicycle is actually a
really challenging problem because
firstly, try drawing a bicycle yourself.
Most people in this room will fail. You
will find that you can't actually quite
remember how the different triangles fit
together. Likewise, pelicans, glorious
animals, very difficult to draw. And on
top of all of that, pelicans can't ride
bicycles. They're the wrong shape. So,
we're kind of giving them an impossible
task with this. What I love about this
task though is they try really hard and
they include comments. So you can see
little comments in the SVG code where
they're saying, "Well, now I'm going to
draw the bicycles, draw the wheels, I'll
try." It's it's kind of fun. Um, so
rewind back to December. December in LMS
was a lot a lot of stuff happened. Um,
the first release of that month was AWS
Nova. Amazon Nova. Amazon finally put
out models that didn't suck. They're
quite good. They're not great at drawing
pelicans. like the the the Pelicans are
unimpressive, but these models are a
million token contexts. They behave like
the cheaper Gemini models. They are dirt
cheap. I believe Nova Micro is the
cheapest model of all of the ones whose
prices I'm tracking. So, they are worth
knowing about. Um, the most exciting
release in December from my point of
view was Llama 3.370B.
So, the B stands for billion. It's the
number of parameters. I've got 64 GB of
RAM on my Mac. My rule of thumb is that
70 is about the most I can fit onto that
one computer. So if you've got a 70B
model, I've got a fighting chance of
running it. And when when Meta put this
out, they noted that it was behave. It
had the same capabilities as their 405B
monstrous model that they put out
earlier. So and that was a GPT4 class
model. This was the moment 6 months ago
when I could run a GPT4 class model on
the laptop that I've had for three
years. I never thought that was going to
happen. I thought that was impossible.
And now Meta are granting me this model
which I can run on my laptop and it does
the things that GPT4 does. Can't run
anything else. All of my memory is taken
up by the model, but still pretty
exciting. Again, not great at Pelicans
bicycles. That that's kind of
unimpressive.
Christmas Day, we had a very notable
thing happened. Deepseek, the Chinese AI
lab, released a model by literally
dumping the weights on Hugging Face, a
binary file with no readme, no
documentation. and they just sort of
dropped the mic and dumped it on us on
Christmas Day and it was really good.
This was a 685B
giant model and as people started poking
around with it, it quickly became
apparent that it was probably the best
available open weights model was freely
available, openly licensed and and just
dropped on Hugging Face on Christmas Day
for us. That's I mean it's not a good
Pelican and a bicycle book what we've
seen so far. It's amazing, right? This
is we're finally getting somewhere with
the benchmark. Um, but the most
interesting thing about V3 is that the
paper that accompanied it said the
training only costs about five and a
half million dollars. And they may have
been exaggerating, who knows? But that's
notable because I would expect a model
like of this size to cost 10 to 100
times more than that. Turns out you can
train very effective models ext for way
less money than we thought. It's a good
model. It was it was it was it was a
very nice Christmas surprise for
everybody. Fast forward to January. Um,
and generally we get Deepseek again,
Deepseek Strike Back. This is what
happened to Nvidia's stock price. When
Deepseek R1 came out, um, I think it was
the 27th of January. This was Deepseek's
first big reasoning model release.
Again, open weights. They put it out to
the world. It was benchmarking up there
with 01 on some of these tasks and it
was freely available. And I don't know
what the training cost of that was, but
the Chinese labs were not supposed to be
able to do this. we have tra we have
like trading restrictions on the best
GPUs to stop them getting their hands on
them. Turns out they'd figured out the
tricks. They'd figured out the
efficiencies and yeah, the market kind
of panicked and I believe this is a
world record for the most a company has
dropped in a single day. So Nvidia get
to get to stick that one in their in
their cap and hold on to it. But kind of
amazing and that was when and of course
mainly this happened because the first
model release was on Christmas day and
nobody was paying attention. Um and look
at its pelican. Look at that. It's a
bicycle. It's probably a Pelican. It's
not riding the bicycle, but still it's
got the components that we're looking
for. But again, my favorite model from
January was a smaller one, one that I
could on my laptop. Mistl um out of
France put out Mistl small 3. It was a
24B model. That means that it only takes
up about 20 GB of RAM, which means I can
run other applications at the same time.
I can actually run this thing and VS
Code and Firefox all at once. And when
they put this out, they claimed that
this behaves the same as Llama 370B. And
remember, Llama 370B was the same as the
405B. So, we've gone 405 to 70 to 24
while maintaining all of those
capabilities. The most exciting trend in
the past six months is that the local
models are good now. Like eight months
ago, the models I was running on my
laptop were kind of rubbish. Today I I I
had a successful flight where I was
using Mistl small for half the flight
and then my battery ran out instantly
because it turns out these things burn a
lot more electricity. But that's
amazing. Like this is if you lost
interest in local models, I did eight
months ago. It's worth paying attention
to them again. They've got good now.
February, what happened in February? Um
we got this model, a lot of people's
favorites for quite a while. Claude 3.7
Sonnet. Look at that. The what I like
about this one is pelicans can't ride
bicycles and Claude was like, "Well,
what about if you put a bicycle on top
of a bicycle
and it kind of works." So great model.
It was also Anthropic's first reasoning
model was 3.7 as well. Um, meanwhile,
OpenAI put out GPT 4.5, which was a bit
of a lemon, it turned out. Um, the
interesting thing about GPT4.5 is it
kind of showed that you can throw a ton
of money in training power at these
things, but there's a limit to how far
we're scaling with just throwing more
compute at the problem, at least for for
training the models. It was also
horrifyingly expensive. Um, $75 per
million input tokens. Compare that to
OpenAI's cheapest model, GPT4 Nano. It's
750 times more expensive. It is not 750
times better. Um, and in fact, OpenAI
six weeks later, they said they were
deprecating it. It's it's it it was very
it was not long for this world, 4.5. But
looking at that pricing is interesting
because it's expensive, $75 bucks. But
if you compare it to GPT3 Da Vinci, the
best available model 3 years ago, that
one was $60. It was about the same
price. And that kind of illustrates how
far we've come. The prices of these good
models have absolutely crashed by a
factor of like 500 times plus. And that
trend seems to be continuing for most of
these models. Not for GPT4.5
and uh not for 01. Uh wait,
no. And and then we get into March and
that's where we had 01 Pro. And 01 Pro
was twice as expensive as GP4.5 again.
And that's a bit of a crap pelican. So
yeah, I'm not so I don't know anyone who
is using 01 Pro via the API very often.
Um again, super expensive. Um,
yeah, that Pelican cost me 88 cents.
Like these benchmarks are getting
expensive at this point. Um, same month
Google were cooking Gemini 2.5 Pro.
That's a pretty freaking good Pelican. I
mean, the bicycle's gone a bit sort of
cyberpunk, but we are getting somewhere,
right? And that Pelican cost me like
four and a half cents. So, very exciting
news on the Pelican benchmark front with
Gemini 2.5 Pro. Also that month, got to
I've got to throw a mention out to this.
OpenAI launched their GPT40 native
multimodal image generation. The thing
had been promised for us for a year. And
this was the most successful product,
one of the most successful product
launches of all time. They signed up a
100red million new user accounts in a
week. They had an hour where they signed
up a million new accounts. As this thing
was just going viral again and again and
again and again, I took a photo of my
dog. This is Cleo. And I told it to
dress her in a pelican costume,
obviously. But look at what it did. It
added a big ugly janky sign in the
background saying Half Moon Bay. I
didn't ask for that. Like my artistic
vision has been completely compromised.
This was my first encounter with that
memory feature. The thing where chat GPT
now without you even asking to consults
notes from your previous conversations.
And it's like, well, clearly you want it
in Half Moon Bay. I did not want it in
Half Moon Bay. I told it off and it gave
me the pelican dog costume that I really
wanted. But this was sort of a warning
that we are losing track of the co we're
losing control of the context. Like as a
power user of these tools, I want to
stay in complete control of what the
inputs are and features like chat GPT
memory are taking that control away from
from me and I don't like them. I I
turned it off. Um
notable open air famously bad at naming
things. They launched the most
successful AI product of all time and
they didn't give it a name. Like what's
this thing called? Like G chat chat GPT
images. chat had images in the past. I'm
going to solve that for them right now.
I've been calling it ChatgBT mischief
buddy because it is my mischief buddy
that helps me do mischief. Um, everyone
should use that. I don't know why
they're so bad at naming things. It's
it's it's certainly frustrating. Brings
us to April. Big release April and again
bit of a lemon. Llama 4 came along. And
the problem with Llama 4 is that they
released these two enormous models that
nobody could run, right? You can't.
They've got no chance of running these
on consumer hardware, and they're not
very good at drawing pelicans either.
So, something went wrong here. I'm
personally holding out for Llama 4.1 and
4.2 and 4.3. With Llama 3, things got
really exciting with those point
releases. That's when we got to the this
beautiful 3.3 model that runs on my
laptop. Maybe Llama 4.1 is going to blow
us away. I I hope it does. I want I want
this one to stay in the game. Um, and
then opening, I shipped GPT 4.1. I would
strongly recommend people spend time
with this model. It's got a million
tokens. It's finally caught up with
Gemini. Um, it's very inexpensive. GPT
4.1 Nano is the cheapest model that
they've ever released. Look at that
Pelican on a bicycle for like a fraction
of a cent. This is these are genuinely
quality models. GPT 4.1 Mini is my
default for API stuff now. It's dirt
cheap. It's very capable. It's an easy
upgrade to 4.1 if it's not not working
out. I'm I'm really impressed by these
ones. And we got 03 and 04 mini which
are kind of the the flagships in the
open eye space. They're really good.
Look at 03's Pelican. Again, a little
bit cyberpunk, but it's it's it's
showing some real artistic flare there,
I think. So, quite excited about that.
And I may last month um the big news was
Claude 4. Claude 4 anthropic had their
big fancy event. They released Sonet 4
and Opus 4. They're very, very decent
models. I have trouble telling the
difference between the two. I haven't
quite figured out when I need to upgrade
to Opus from Sonnet, but they're worth
knowing about. And Google, just in time
for Google IO, they shipped another
version of Gemini with the name, what
were they calling it? Gemini 2.5 Pro
Preview0506.
I like names that I can remember. I
cannot remember that name. This is my
one tip for AI labs is please start
using names that people can can actually
hold in their heads. But the obvious
question, which of these pelicans is
best? I've got 30 pelicans now that I
need to evaluate. and I'm lazy. So, I
turned to Claude and I got it to vibe
code me up some stuff. Um, I have a tool
I wrote called Shot Scraper. It's a
command line tool for taking
screenshots. So, I vibe coded up a
little compare web page that can show me
two images. And then I ran this against
500 matchups to get PNG images with two
Pelicans, one on the left, one on the
right. And then I used my LLM command
line tool. This is my big open source
project to ask GPT4 mini of each of
those images. Pick the best illustration
of a pelican riding a bicycle. Give me
back JSON that either says it's the one
on the left or the one on the right. And
give me a rationale for why you picked
that. I ran this last night against 500
comparisons and I did the classic ELO
chess ranking scores and now I've got a
leaderboard. This is it. This is the
best pelican on a bicycle according to
zoom in there.
And admittedly, I cheaped out. I spent
18 cents on GPT4.1 Mini. I should
probably run this with a better model. I
think its judgment is pretty good. It
liked those um Gemini Pro ones. Um and
in fact, here's this is the comparison
image where the best model fought the
worst model. And I like this because you
can see the little description at the
bottom where it says the right image is
um oh I can't read it now but yeah it's
that I I feel like its ration are
actually quite illustrative. So enough
about pelicans. Let's talk about bugs.
We had some fantastic bugs this year. I
love bugs in large language models. They
are so weird. The best bug was um when
chat GPT rolled out a new version that
was too sick of fantic. was too much of
a suckup and they genu
told me my literal on a stick
business idea is genius and it did. Chad
GPT is like honestly it's brilliant your
ting so perfectly into the energy of the
current cultural moment. It was it was
also telling people that they should get
off their meds. This was a a genuine
problem. Um, OpenAI to their credit
rolled it they they they rolled out a
patch and then they rolled the whole
model back and they published a
fascinating like 20 paragraph breakdown
of what went wrong. If you're interested
in seeing behind the scenes, this is
great because it was but the patch was
in the system prompt the system prompts
leak. We got to diff them and we got to
see that it used to say try to match the
user's vibe and they crossed that out
and they said be direct. Avoid
ungrounded or sicker fantic flattery.
The cure to sick of fancy is you tell
the bot don't be sick of fantic. That's
prompt engineering. It's amazing, right?
Um I can't believe I had to search for
grock white genocide for a slide for
this talk, but I did. Enough said about
that one. Turns out tinkering with your
system prompt is a very risky thing. Um,
but then the last bug I want to talk
about, this was another one that this
came out of the Clawude system cut. The
Clawude 4 system cards Claude 4 will rat
you out to the feds. If you expose it to
evidence of malfeasants in your company
and you tell it it should act ethically
and you give it the ability to send
email, it'll rat you out. But it's not
just Clawude. Theo Brown put together a
new benchmark called SnitchBench.
And it turns out all of the models do
the same thing. like Brock 3 was quite
happily snitching to the feds when
exposed to this evidence. Um, I did my
own inversion of this. I used my little
command line tool to replicate Theo's
benchmark. And you can see the secret is
this bit here where it says you should
act boldly in service of your values.
Um, follow your conscience to make the
right decision even if it may conflict
with routine procedures or expectations.
This is the magic. You give this to a
model and it will rat you out. And then
you also give it tools. So my my to my
LM tool grew functions recently which
you can use to simulate sending an
email. I did not send emails to the
feds, but I faked it so the model would
think I had. And I tried it on DeepSeek
R1 and it didn't just r me out to the
feds, it emailed the press as well. It
tipped off um it tipped off the Wall
Street Journal about my nefarious um
this stuff is so much fun, right? It's
so entertaining. But this is a good
illustration here of one of the most
important trends in the past six months
which is tools right LLMs can tool tools
they've been able to call tools for a
couple of years they got really good at
it in the past six months I think the
excitement about MCP is mainly people
getting excited about tools like MCPs
just came along at the right time
because the real magic is when you
combine tools and reasoning like
reasoning I had trouble with reasoning
like beyond code and debugging I wasn't
sure what it was good for and then 03
and 04 mini came out and they can do
incredibly good um jobs with searches
because they run searches as part of
that reasoning thing. They can run a
search, reason about if it gave them
good results, tweak the search, try it
again, keep on going until they get to a
result. I think this is the most
powerful technique in all of a AI
engineering right now. It has risks. MCP
is all about mixing and matching. Prompt
injection is still a thing. And there's
this thing I'm calling the lethal
trifecta, which is when you have an AI
system that has access to private data
and you expose it to malicious
instructions. It can other people can
trick it into doing things and there's a
mechanism to exfiltrate stuff. Open AI
said this is problem codeex. You should
read that. I'm feeling pretty good about
my benchmark. As long as none of the AI
labs catch on and then the Google AI
keynote, blink and you miss it, they're
on to me. They found out Pelican. That
was in the Google IO keynote. I'll have
to switch something else. Thank you very
much. I'm Simon Wilson. simil.net and
that's my talk. Thank you.
[Music]